I'm a chemist and chemists got really
excited when Macintosh computers started
and they were really good because you
could draw pictures of molecules but
chemists to begin with anyway we're not
very good with computers and they often
crashed I had all sorts of problems when
I started with my first Mac so I was
given a present
the computers long gone but I've still
got the present and it's in this box it
comes with a manual it's called a
smacker Mac and the manual is really
quite formal as a registration card
the warranty limited and warranty on
replacement so let's look at this Mac
Mac itself it's a squashy toy that looks
like the original Mac computer and the
idea was that when you got frustrated
with the computer instead of kicking the
computer or smashing it you would
strangle the smacker Mac or throw it
across the room
go on actually I never threw it across
the room it had such a friendly face but
still and it's been sitting there in its
box smiling at me in my study for 25
years since I had my first Macintosh
professor I can't help noticing you
don't have a Macintosh now yeah what
happened unfortunately I was really like
Macintosh computers but the university
decided that pcs were better and so I
was persuaded the delegation came and
said professor if you change everybody
else will so I was persuaded really what
persuaded me was in those days that PC
laptops were much lighter than Macintosh
ones and so it was much easier when you
were wandering around carrying these
laptops now all my colleagues are
changing back to Mac
but I've got used to PCs and they're
more people who can help me with pcs
when things go wrong some people give
you no exercise by this don't they do
you enter the debate is that something
you even think about I never really
worry very much about computers I want
one that works that's easy to use and
the problem with Macs and PCs are that
they're both easy to use but they're
different you have to click on one side
of a window when you wanted to shut on
the PC the opposite side on the Mac and
things like that so you can't easily use
both unless you're young and the other
problem is that certainly I find that
their compatibility issues between the
programs they work 99 percent but the
one percent of the time an arrow will
suddenly swell up when you go from one
computer to the other or some symbol or
some strange character won't transfer
properly I have noticed though in in
recent times you've transitioned to the
iPhone how are you finding the iPhone I
was given an iPhone as part of my job as
foreign secretary of the Royal Society I
quite like the iPhone but I haven't
bought any apps at all so I'm just using
it for email and to take pictures and
it's okay but and I also have an iPad
but again I preferred using my laptop or
PC if I want to do some serious piece of
writing
you
we have an ingot of platinum this weighs
13 he lived and used so in fact it's
used very regularly to make electronic
components all of the computers that we
use in actually the camera that you're
recording me on now are based upon
silicon technology